we might finally know what devil fruit
Awakening really is how it works and why
using it might mean paying the ultimate
price for Luffy because the One Piece
manga just dropped some bombshell
information about the origin of devil
fruits and how these fruits work which
shockingly enough has gone completely
unnoticed by many people due to the
faulty English translations I will link
a video with the full literal
translation at the end of this one but
in essence Dr vegapunk reveals who the
straw hats that devil fruits are born
into this world by people's dreams and
wishes for the future and that devil
fruit users are actually beings created
from someone else's imagination that
live in a different dimension which is
already huge but on top of that we have
an epic Clash between Luffy in his
awakened Sungod Nika State and Rob Luchi
who has also awakened his leopard Zone
devil fruit that looks like this now if
you also thought that the fiery Vapor
thing around Luffy was unique to his
devil fruit ability but turns out it's
not and with luchi's Awakening sharing
so many similarities with Luffy's we can
finally deduce a lot about how devil
fruit Awakening actually works and why
it is so incredibly dangerous now to
give you a very quick overview on what
we already know about devil fruit
Awakening so far there are actually only
10 Canon characters that have been
officially confirmed as awakened devil
fruit users which is kind of crazy when
you think about it four of them are the
jailers in imple down and then we have
doflamingo karakuri law kids Luffy and
Lucy that's it and you'll notice that
half of them have only been revealed
like super recently in the story now the
first time that Awakening was ever
officially mentioned was by doflamingo
during his fight with Luffy he showed us
that there was a completely new unknown
level to devil fruit powers that
increases their base abilities immensely
this power up depends heavily though on
the type of devil fruit that you have
eaten Zone food users can turn into some
sort of animal like Dragon a mammoth or
a leopard which gives them all of that
creatures you need abilities as well as
generally boosted power and endurance
lokia devil fruit users turn their body
into some sort of substance or elements
such as fire sand or electricity and
paramecia type devil fruits kind of
lazily I guess basically cover
everything else like big moms and Brook
Soul Foods whitebeard's earthquake food
or Sugar's ability to turn anything she
touches into toys and as vegapunk
explains each of these fruits are
created because someone keeps wishing
for their existence so the ability to
turn into a dragon the ability to freeze
anything or the ability to turn anything
into a toy though how exactly this works
is still a little bit unclear vegapunk
himself claims that he's not interested
in whether this is some sort of ancient
technology or if it's some sort of magic
created by a Gods by the way if you want
to feel like a God if you hit subscribe
under the video I will pay my respects
by offering you high quality one piece
videos every single week now as
doflamingo shows us Awakening your
powers as a paramecia type user means
that your abilities would not only
affect your body but also the
environment around you and amplify that
abilities Powers as a result doflamingo
himself was able to transform any
objects around him into controllable
strings that he could also manipulate
without actually being in contact with
them similarly katakuri was able to
transform the area around him into Mochi
and control it as part of his body as
well kit could affect his environment
with his magnetic powers and meanwhile
for someone like law instead of creating
a room in which he usually controls
objects in his awakened State law can
apply his manipulation field on objects
like his sword for instance which he
then calls a crew and this way the sword
now gains the same spatial manipulation
abilities that usually only work with a
room around himself for example using a
tech unique called anesthesia he enables
his sword to spatially face through
anything without ever having to make a
wound or creating an incision which is
pretty handy because you can thereby
bypass any type of Defense when it comes
to low gear fruit users so far we've
seen no officially confirmed example of
one that's awakened but it's wildly
speculated that an awakened lokia fruit
user would be able to not only turn his
body into an element but similar to
paramecia types also affect the
environment around them for example Punk
hazard's climate used to be a jungle
island but after the epic battle between
aokiji and the kainu it ended up being
half Frozen wastelands and half fiery
lava Fields Zone fruits on the other
hand work entirely differently but we
first really learned about Awakening on
dressrosa the first time this was
actually mentioned as a concept was by
crocodile during Luffy's prison break
from impel down there the four Jayla
beasts akao a koala Areno and a zebra
all four are our awakened Zone type
devil fruit users this basically turns
them into giant monster-like versions of
their respective animals but with
certain human features still remaining
like arms and legs now these four
awakened users act on pure animal
instincts and have basically lost all
their human will and this is of course
very similar to Chopper's monster Point
form before the time skip at least which
has led to the generally accepted theory
that Chopper's monster point is an
artificially created state of Awakening
however we now have at least two more
examples of Awakened Zone producers that
are nothing like monster Point Chopper
or the impel down guards that completely
lose their human nature with Luffy's
Awakening of his mythical Nika devil
fruit we can definitely see a
personality change in Luffy but he still
is himself and aware of his goals
whether that is defeating kaido or
keeping Luchi from murdering more people
in vegapan's lap now originally could
have simply been explained by Luffy
having eaten a human type devil fruit
and a mythical one at that but now with
Rob Lucci's Awakening we have
confirmation that it's very much
possible to retain mental control in
your awakened State and Luchi also
doesn't look at all like the brainless
monster versions of the imple down
animals as well instead his leopard has
grown slim and Powerful looking and even
more human than his original hybrid form
I would say and maybe most importantly
he has the same wheel of flame and smoke
around him as Luffy has in his gear 5
State so it does seem that at least for
his own fruits there are two paths to
Awakening one where you completely lose
control and the spirit of the animal
consumes you and one where you unlock
that animal's full potential while still
staying in control of yourself as a
human being now even though Luchi and
Luffy are the only two characters with
this form that have been officially
confirmed as awakened there are two more
likely candidates here the most obvious
of the two is Yamato son of yonko kaido
now she has eaten the mythical dog fruit
model okotino makami which is a Divine
wolf when she's facing her own father in
battle because Luffy fell into the ocean
Yamato seems to be in her hybrid form
however since we have now seen Luchi
with the same slim figure and Vapor code
around him it's pretty safe to say that
this is actually Yamato's awakened form
which would make sense because how else
would Yamato be able to keep her father
at Bay and then kaido himself is of
course the second possible Awakening
here so everyone's surprise kaido was
never officially confirmed to have
awakened his devil fruit and so it is
possible that he just never did after
all the fight against kaido was mostly a
battle of armaments and conquerors
hockey plus kaido also seems to lack
that Vapor code that Luffy Yamato and
Luchi have so prominently however kaido
does seem to have two distinct hybrid
forms one that looks a lot more like his
human form and one that looks a lot more
like a dragon phase with human features
that second one also has these flame
patterns like for example with his
eyebrows similar to the flame shape of
luchi's fur interestingly enough though
in his Dragon form kaido actually does
have that exam Vapor code and the
flame-shaped fur just like Luchi or like
Yamato so I would simply speculate based
on just that that kaido was indeed
awakened as the king of beasts should
really be if we're being honest but that
still doesn't explain what Awakening
truly is I mean from doflamingo and
katakuri we know that Awakening wants
devil fruit at least naturally requires
a certain amount of power as well as a
great Mastery of one's devil fruit
ability and we also know from law and
kids that fighting in once awakened
State takes a huge toll on the user's
body and energy and can only be used for
a quite limited time but the key here I
think is vegapunk's explanation devil
food Powers basically tap into abilities
that exist in different dimensions yes
Oda literally uses the words different
dimension in the manga by the way and
mega Punk also goes into even more
detail with Luffy's Nika fruit he
explains that even though Nika's name
was erased from history as long as
people keep wishing for his existence he
can never be erased so it does seem like
eating a devil fruit means that a user
not only takes on the abilities that
have been wished for but also the reason
for why it was wished for in the first
place in other words based on vegapunk's
explanation devil fruit users seem to
inherit the will of those who wish for
the power in the first place kaido tells
Luffy that Awakening happens when the
Mind catches up to the devil fruit and
Oda himself had actually revealed
something very similar to this in the
road to love tale booklets while the
manga was on break he explained to us
that the downside of Zone Awakenings is
that the innate nature of the animal
mole can consume the user if they're not
being careful which does seem to be
exactly what happened with the guards at
dimple down or with chopper when he
completely loses control and so I would
say that this is something that actually
seems to be quite dangerous for Luffy as
well if the Nika fruit is born by people
wishing for it then that explains
Luffy's extremely strange Behavior while
in gear 5. let's look at why that is
who's who the person who was supposed to
guard the Nika fruit for the government
before it was then stolen by Shanks
tells jimbei about Nika's history
basically that he's that legendary
figure that slaves pray to in the hope
that they would bring smiles to their
faces and freedom from their suffering
he also mentions that he doesn't know
whether or not he actually used to exist
or if he was simply dreamed up which was
of course perfect foreshadowing for this
entire devil fruits are born from dreams
reveal so what seems to be happening
here is that the essence of Nika is
bringing smiles to people's faces and
freeing them from their suffering now
remember when Luffy awakened the
citizens of wano literally wished for
just that and it was Luffy's promise and
purpose in his fight against kaido to
liberate the people of wano therefore
Luffy could only awaken his devil fruit
once he had truly embodied the essence
of his Nika devil fruit and so while he
hasn't been overtaken by his fruit so
far like dimple down jailers he still
seems to have become a different person
in the states I mean let's look at the
facts normally Luffy takes big fights
very seriously but in his awakened State
he suddenly can't stop laughing and uses
his powers in quirky ways that he seems
to find amusing and he does seem to take
things a little bit too lightly as well
overseeing that Luchi is attacking sento
Maru for instance which I would argue
could well be the true nature of the sun
god Nika trying to take him over in
other words this might well be a major
risk for Luffy going forward losing
control and having Nika slash Joy boy
literally come out instead stats but of
course it's not only Luffy devil fruits
carrying the will of those who dreamed
them up explains why pretty much any
devil fruit user fits his fruit Powers
almost perfectly personality wise I mean
think about it though Flamingo has the
string fruit and is extremely
manipulative Yamato who is the guardian
deity of mono a dog is extremely loyal
straightforward and decides to put the
safety of wano over their desire to go
out to sea both big Mom and Mother
caramel had the Soulful fruit and both
love to control people's lives and
existence akinu has the magma fruit and
is basically always boiling over with
hot rage the list goes on and on and on
so Awakening one's devil fruit might
simply mean becoming one with the
original real and intention behind its
creation maybe the one who dreamed of
the string fruit wanted to control and
manipulate things and though Flamingo
became so controlling and manipulative
that he was able to up into the fruit's
full potential after being perfectly
aligned with it or in luchi's case
someone who would dream up a leopard
would want to hunt and kill their prey
and I mean Luchi was always a
bloodthirsty Hunter and at some point I
guess he just matched the nature of his
devil fruit so perfectly that he could
awaken it and this also works really
well with the idea that you have to
master your devil fruit too because
mastering wants fruit means nothing else
than using it in the way that it was
meant to be used so the only real
question now is how exactly people's
dreams and wishes can be turned into
actual physical abilities in the one
piece world for that I have personally
translated vegapunk's full lecture about
devil fruits from Japanese and discussed
this question and much much more in a
lot of detail in this video right here
so check that out if you're interested